at 8 a.m. on a hot morning in June more
than 50 miners started digging for gold
in the newly opened calico mines in Los
Angeles but despite their seven-day
workweek will never find a single nugget
these are animatronics how do my day the
miner started their Sisyphean workday
after reopening ceremony at Knott's
Berry Farm in LA the morning featured a
low-key appearance from one man who most
people won't recognize by his face or
even his signature Hawaiian shirt this
is garner holt and even though you won't
see his name anywhere on the ride he
designed and built these miners it's
almost like a magician and then people
just look and stare and disbelief
it's like wow that's just amazing and
what I've just seen and that's kind of
what we do this is kind of like you know
three-dimensional magic my parents
always wanted me to be a veterinarian
until that one fateful day that they
took me to Disneyland I remember walking
through Disneyland and seeing the parts
the carribean in the Haunted Mansion
something struck me how did that work
how did it all function how was it
possible that these these things that
obviously weren't alive looked like real
people I just decided at that very
moment that's what I wanted to do the
rest of my life I felt a little shack
and called it a haunted house that was
my first commercial endeavor as my
haunted house $0.10 a ticket there was a
starting ground and it was the very
beginning cigar home productions making
a lifelike robot requires proficiency in
so many different arts and technologies
it's hard to imagine garnets company
does it all under one roof we develop it
on screen we carve it sculpted making
skins body shells costume a mechanical
electrical maddox programming makeup and
figure finishing writing and sound and
special effects
get it on sites follow it and maintain
it basically what we're creating is the
illusion of life that's not really very
easy garner Holt production is currently
a 70 person company has produced
thousands of figures they've made over
400 for Disney everything from Pixar
characters to a 45 foot tall
fire-breathing dragon a lot of people
say well what does an animatronic figure
cost and you know I usually equate it to
a car I'll turn it around on them and
I'll say what does a car cost and
they'll say well what kind of car you
know and I'll say yeah exactly we've
sold human characters for 25 or 30
thousand and we've sold human characters
for a million dollars and they're all
human characters but it just depends on
what they do animatronics can be very
cost intensive but you know when you
look at what it does for a ride or
something in a park and they perform
over and over and over again they pay
for their keep
occasionally you reach this strange
thing called the uncanny valley it's a
spot in which you actually have a fear
of something because it looks so real
and you realize it's not I've had a
number of characters that we've done
people have you know seen it at a
distance and walked up to it
and believed it was a real person third
and they're very surprised and they're
startled if you can bring out some
emotions somebody that's the best
feeling in the world